in our series state of testing experts
say some states are still not doing
enough coronavirus tests we are four
months now into the pandemic cars lined
up for what looked like miles outside a
testing site a Dodger Stadium in Los
Angeles yesterday and in Texas many
people have waited in line for hours for
a corona virus test more than 200,000
people keep in mind in that state have
now tested positive and more than 2,700
have died while more via Franken now
reports on the testing problems
stephannie West is a nurse at a plasma
Center in Killeen Texas the fear for me
was always catching it and spraying it
to somebody else after driving more than
an hour he waited more than four hours
at an Austin testing site before he was
swapped can you see how that might
discourage people absolutely I'm
surprised that I didn't see more people
leave how would you describe the process
to somebody who's kind of on the fence
about getting your tests it's gonna be
something that's you have to commit to
it's not gonna be pleasant it's not fun
but that's not the point the point is
safeguarding yourself and others here in
Dallas this location was testing 600
people a day and maxing out so they
increased their capacity to 1000 tests
and for the second day in a row they
maxed out the demand for tests is so
great that we're told people start
lining up at 6 a.m. this was a scene
last week in Houston before Texas
reopened in late April health officials
were processing nearly 15,000 tests a
day now it's over 50,000 but the state
falls behind 41 others in terms of tests
performed per 100,000 people and
according to targets laid out by the
Harvard Global Health Institute Texas
would need to increase testing to 117
thousand people a day to keep the
outbreak under control
health officials say the Lone Star State
faces challenges because of its size and
demographics Rebecca Fisher is an
epidemiologist at Texas A&M School
of Public Health well in Texas we we
have Earl populations we have urban
populations we have everything in
between and then hidden populations just
like other space individuals who may be
immigrants or might be without resources
without homes without transportation the
need for more tests is only part of the
equation says interim health authority
and Austin public health dr. Marc Escott
but the problem is that we have lag in
terms of results of those tests so that
becomes a point where it doesn't make
sense to test more people if we can't
get results back in a timely fashion to
do anything about those positive tests
Stuart Way Mack who lives in Caldwell
County Texas was able to walk right into
the public testing site he visited later
quest Diagnostics which has processed
nearly a fifth of u.s. coronavirus tests
says demand particularly in the south
has outpaced capacity it says most
turnaround times have now increased by a
day or two we need that person to be
tested so that we can initiate then the
next chain of events that happens in the
public health response and that is to
seek out their contact if we could cut
off an infectious persons time
circulating the community by one day or
two days this would be huge in Austin
public testing was open to everyone but
because of the high demand they had to
modify who could get tested limiting it
to people who are showing symptoms
people who are high risk and essential
workers and Vlad health officials are
saying people who have private health
insurance they're asking them to seek
out other options and as you know Texas
is lagging 41 other states when it comes
to testing Omar thank you very much